today the Porsche 356 numbers among the
truly classic sports cars in 1948 it
became the first automobile to proudly
bear the porsche name before then
Ferdinand Porsche had developed cars for
various other brands at the porsche
design and engineering firm he'd founded
in 1931 and stood guide
they ask the faucet but our classic car
expert christoph bauer tells us that the
first porsche wasn't actually built in
stuttgart but in the austrian town of
Jamuna near the end of the Second World
War the company had moved its entire
operations there to escape the constant
bombing raids and the 356 wasn't the
brainchild of patriarch ferdinand
porsche rather it was his son ferry who
created the sports car out of VW parts
his father praised ferries work and said
he wouldn't change a single screw
Ferdinand Porsche was one of the auto
industry's pioneers starting in 1897 he
developed electric and hybrid vehicles
an all-electric drive model and
trend-setting mid-engined race cars like
the Ostrow Daimler Sasha and the Auto
Union Silver Arrow
but in Christoph tells us that early
versions of the Porsche 356 had a
souped-up beetle engine under the hood
which barely produced 40 horsepower
that's not really enough for a sports
car but he says it's fun all the same
the car is clever aerodynamics and
lightweight construction let it reach
140 kilometres an hour
Zubov annotate onto fallacies cut if I'm
against windows what's work
during the 17 years the 356 was produced
Porsche continued to make improvements
this super 90 convertible from 1960 is
among the most fully perfected versions
its 1.6 liter 90 horsepower engine is
over twice as powerful as the motor in
the original 356
as an important as mr. feels that the
Porsche 356 is not only a blast to drive
it's a feast for the senses to the
bakelite steering wheel the leather
seats these buttons here everything
gives you the impression of being made
to last the car's body was designed by
engineer Aaron commenda who'd already
given shape to auto unions Grand Prix
sports cars and the VW Beetle christophe
says the 356 is a true milestone in
automotive history that formed the basis
for Porsches design language he says any
new 911 is really just a modern variant
of the 356 that it's the Anglican East
analyst animal Diana re-enter districts
Infiniti
it's face is immediately recognizable
the round headlights and prominent wings
have essentially become part of Porsches
DNA the gently sloping rear is also a
Porsche specialty
although the teardrop aerodynamic design
is now seen as dated
the ignition is found to the left of the
steering wheel the tachometer is
centrally located and the ergonomics are
stellar these features Porsche drivers
have come to know and love all came from
the 356 that's Cristo says the heart of
the 356 can be found back here while the
first 356 is used beetle engines this
one was already fitted with a
four-cylinder 1.6 liter porsche boxer
engine and boosts under head cams and
generates 90 horsepower impart thanks to
these two Solex carburetors the standard
engines had 60 and 75 horsepower
there was a 130 horsepower variant with
a very complicated vertical shaft engine
but he says this here is the finest one
you can get
the boxer engines are viewed as reliable
and long-lasting then as now Porsches
are often known as sensible sports cars
which makes them unique christophe says
that when Porsche announced it would be
introducing a successor model fans and
automotive journalists claimed that a
new Porsche could never outdo the old
356 well the 911 has certainly made more
than a few friends over the years and as
the forefather to the 911 the first
Porsche ever the 356 is definitely an
automotive milestone definite even Milan
style the automobile existed
today it's still a pleasure to take a
356 convertible out for a spin on the
picture s roads of Trentino and northern
Italy after the 356 was discontinued in
1965 porsche buyers had to wait until
1982 for the introduction of the 911
convertible until they could once again
feel the wind in their hair